[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date année
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'historial aux riffs chavanette pour
son livre danton et robespierre le choc
de la révolution est même l'un des plus
grands chocs de l'histoire de france
puisque leur opposition leur duel se
perpétue jusqu'à nos jours mais
commençons pas l'image que vous avez
choisi pour symboliser notre époque
alors qu'est ce qu'elle représente
vous reconnaissez peut-être emmanuel
macron premièrement ensuite la sorbonne
c'est les funérailles de samuel pâtit
professeur d'histoire passionné de ses
élèves professeurs d'énergie professeur
de la laïcité est pourquoi je les
choisis parce que cette image
incarne à la fois la guerre dans
laquelle nous vivons une guerre contre
le terrorisme et le fanatisme
un fanatisme et en même temps l'héroïsme
donc il ya à la fois la peur et
l'admiration et la reconnaissance là par
les autorités publiques de ce ce petit
professeur qui est devenu un grand homme
pour toute la nation
et bien commençons
[Musique]
danton et robespierre le choc de la
révolution paraître aux éditions passées
composer avec une préface d' emmanuel de
waresquiel en lisant votre livre on voit
bien que l'opposition entre danton et
robespierre alors que tout semblait les
unir cristallise comme vous dites deux
acceptions de la modernité politique qui
existe encore aujourd'hui en 2021
disons que c'est sûr que danton
robespierre c'est à la fois la
révolution mais ce sont deux visages
assez différent en fait de la révolution
elle même et de la démocratie c'est sur
le côté pur incorruptibles de
robespierre c'est une forme d'idéal de
république à l'antique
austère où il faut se sacrifier pour le
bien public et dans ton plus libéral
plus de séparation entre la vie privée
et la vie publique
peut-être plus de vis peut-être plus de
modération de tolérance de capacité de
de créer des compromis en politique de
convaincre l'autre
n'ont pas seulement lui faire peur
ces deux ces deux là font toujours notre
modernité politique à l'horizon au début
de la révolution dans ton à 29 ans
robespierre en est 30 ils sont avocats
tous les deux ils sont provinciaux il
son retour y est au fond c'est là où on
veut tous les unit au départ un ils ont
une même vision de la révolution mais il
en fait il se ils se ressemblent
énormément
dans cette société d'ancien régime ils
subissent les un peu les injustices de
l'ancien régime de la monarchie très
bureaucratique etc alors oui il ya une
promotion sociale les deux dans ton
était petit fils de paysan même si son
père était procureur la famille de
robespierre était elle aussi deux des
hommes 2
de loi de droit et tous les deux vont
devenir avocat
mais dans deux registres différents
alors oui ils se ressemblent parce que
comme beaucoup de leur génération qui va
faire la révolution de 89 ils sont des
jurisconsultes d'abord des hommes du
droit et ils vont être ceux qui vont
faire la révolution c'est à dire casser
les normes existantes donc c'est presque
trahir le droit que d'entrer en
révolution mais ils ont une même idéal
la poursuite de l'égalité de la liberté
de l'émancipation qui recherchent et en
tant que bourgeois gagner des places
parce que la révolution c'est une lutte
politique juridique mais aussi social où
ils vont vouloir s'imposer absolument et
or justement comment se fait-il
connaître parce qu'il faut imaginer ce
que c'est la convocation des états
généraux qui va donner en fait la
révolution entre avril et juillet
1789 il ya comme ça une irruption de
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes gens ils
sont dans les plus jeunes un
robespierre il est élu député d'arras
danton lui est un tribun populaire de la
rive gauche
il est pas du tout là au moment de la
prise de la bastille qui n'est pas
l'image qu'on voit là là c'est la prise
des tuileries choix mais là il est il
n'est pas encore dans le n'est pas
encore dans le coup mais mais très vite
il va il va apparaître avec le club des
cordeliers comment se fait connaître
parce que c'est une compétition est
extraordinaire
ils sont vous l'avez dit les plus jeunes
robespierre est le plus jeune des
députés élus de l'artois d'arras près
d'arras c'est le plus jeune ils sont
quelques-uns du tiers état être élu
c'est le plus jeune est en général quand
on est jeune on est plus radicale alors
déjà on se démarque par la radicalité
robespierre et très tôt dans la
révolution quelqu'un qui a des idées
non pas extrémistes on dirait pas
extrémiste mais qui a des idées très
avancés sur la démocratie sur les droits
le suffrage universel qu'il défend très
tôt ils sont pas forcément républicain
ni l'un ni l'autre à ce moment là par
personne les républicains d'ailleurs au
départ de la rue début de la révolution
c'est ça la contradiction c'est que
louis saez et et aimer c'est un roi
énormément aimé même si son épouse l'est
beaucoup moins et très impopulaire
depuis plusieurs affaires mais au début
de la révolution louis saez et beaucoup
aimé il est vu comme un roi salvateur et
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fuite de varennes en
4 en juillet 91 on va pouvoir espérer
faire une révolution une monarchie
parlementaire comme en angleterre depuis
un siècle ben voilà on l'a rêvé mais on
ne l'a pas fait on le fera beaucoup plus
tard et ça va pas durer très longtemps
mais effectivement je reviens sur
robespierre qui fait la révolution en
tant que député dans la branche des mots
des démocrates des démocrates avancées
pour une révolution de plus en plus
social et
de l'autre côté à paris parce que
robespierre est élu il est à versailles
mais quasiment pas paris même s'il a
fait ses études à paris à louis-le-grand
mais d'antan lui les goûts l'avait dit
au quartier des cordeliers très
populaire à paris les avocats c'est un
tribun il a une sacrée gueule il a il a
de gros la vaste aux épaules il alla la
lèvre abîmé enfin il a une stature il a
aujourd'hui sa statue d'ailleurs dans ce
quartier là l'ami la bigorre d'aller là
où il habitait encore du commerce et
danton lui va s'imposer par sa voix de
stentor par sa son gigantisme sa verve
qu'il a il ya un verbe d'antonia qui est
unique et pierre est plutôt de mauvais
orateur il commence mal mais il finit
bon orateur il commence très mal il est
énormément moquer on parle de lui comme
de quelqu'un de presque 1 bert de moqué
pour sa jeunesse moqué pour ses idées un
moment il a écrit un journaliste dit que
le moniteur que il lisait quand il
fallait se taire et il est aisé quand
c'était le moment de lire son discours
et d'ailleurs il sait il a été
énormément il a beaucoup souffert de ce
manque de de prestance dans un corps
social comme ça une assemblée de
quelques 800 personnes il avait du mal à
s'imposer par sa voix et 1 800 m que
tout se joue en est un évidemment
puisque c'est les tribuns qu'ils vont
faire si la politique qui a été fait par
des avocats pendant pratiquement un
siècle plus d'un siècle ensuite la
troisième république c'est que des
avocats aussi bah oui mais c'est même ce
que disait napoléon bonaparte c'est ce
sont les avocats qui commence les
révolutions ne sont pas eux qui
déterminent une danton robespierre ont
commencé la révolution et c'est vrai que
robespierre à la tribune il a du mal à
lire ses discours par exemple ce qu'il
écrit ses discours al'inverse de danton
qui lui est tout d'oralité de
jaillissement de deux passions de fougue
d'improvisation il a le génie d'un
produit de l'impro robespierre lui au
contraire les cris pendant des semaines
ces discours et il essaie de les
présenter à l'assemblée et on lui refuse
la parole parfois ils hurlent ils
essaient de se faire entendre donc il
publie ses discours et ainsi va
continuer à souffrir quasiment de
l'injustice de pouvoir s'exprimer de ne
pas pour s'exprimer ce qui va aussi le
pousser dans le camp de plus en plus
radicale oui oui parce qu'on voit dans
votre livre que robespierre en fait
pratiquer la surenchère permanente
jusqu'à devenir un fanatique c'est
l'image qu'on a gardé lui d'ailleurs
celle d'un fanatique alors que dans tout
il est plus pragmatique vous dites il
pense que l'erreur est humaine danton et
il veut pas changer l'humanité alors que
robespierre lui vendent homme nouveau
mais si vous voulez moi j'aime beaucoup
cette expression de cette formule de la
rochefoucauld qui est la suivante qui
est lévis est les hommes alors oui c'est
sûr lui c'était presque un coquin dans
son temps le marquis mais mes
robespierre lui à une exigence de pureté
et pour lui et pour les autres c'est
vrai qu'il n'envisage la vie son
existence que dans la logique d'une
guerre
absolue à mener contre pas seulement les
royalistes les ennemis de la révolution
de la liberté les aristocrates mais
aussi contre les les les hypocrites
contre les riches donc il a un panel de
le très très large d'ennemis des
adversaires contre lesquels ils
ferraillent ferraille sans cesse alors
que danton compose avec lumen faiblesse
lui-même fragilité lui-même ayant des
travers dans sa vie privée mais will est
un réaliste mais il ya aussi quelque
chose de très important on va peut-être
en parlais tout à l'heure je pense c'est
que dans ton est marié avec des enfants
est endetté en 89 quand commence la
révolution robespierre est complètement
libre de tout mouvement on pense même
qu'il est vierge d'ailleurs on ne lui
connaît aucune liaison il n'y a aucune
preuve bon il ya une fille qui vient
parfois le il aurait une
fiancée à arras madame des orties qui
serait mariée avec quelqu'un d'autre
alors que c'était sa promise mais bon ça
veut dire ça veut pas dire qu'il est
consommé quoi que ce soit et il a eu
peut-être une relation à à paris avec
une fille qui venait lui rendre visite
régulièrement et son valet à robespierre
expliqué qu'il l'a traité fort mal et
qu'il ait donné de l'argent il a traité
fort mal bon entre point d'interrogation
mais c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas contracté
de mariage il n'a jamais emprunté
d'argent de sa vie pour acheter un bien
comme d'antan qui va s'enrichir mais
aussi investir et donc l'investissement
appelle la richesse parfois et
robespierre est donc très libre de tout
mouvement et ils habitent même celle m à
partir de la fille de en 91 il habite
chez les duplaix une famille au centre
de paris rue saint-honoré on peut encore
voir la plaque aujourd'hui ici avec gux
robespierre elle est très très
énigmatique et robespierre vivait chez
des gens il ne s'occupait même pas
d'intendance il s'occupait de rien il
était tout dévoué à la révolution alors
que danton avait acquis des biens dans
à côté de chez lui en champagne il
aimait s'occuper de ses chevaux de ses
poules
corruption d'ailleurs il est surpris
plusieurs reprises très tôt il est
soupçonné de corruption d'acheter des
voix et il n'ya jamais enfin on peut le
dire tout de suite il ya jamais eu la
preuve évidente qu'il avait été content
peut-être acheter mais peut-être pas
corrompu responsables mais pas coupables
on dirait alors ils vont faire que ce
commune à plusieurs reprises par exemple
il faut comme ceux commune dans la lutte
contre les ennemis de l'intérieur les
ennemis de l'intérieur c'est le trône
c'est la royauté c'est la fayette aussi
c'est ce qui va donner la prise des
tuileries
les massacres de septembre
la condamnation à mort du roi puisque
vous le disiez le tournant c'est quand
même la fuite à varennes à partir de la
fuite à varennes le roi tout à coup ne
s'exclut de lui-même du processus
révolutionnaire
et provoque la chute de la royauté on
pensait faire une monarchie
constitutionnelle
il n'en est plus question mais un c'est
vrai quel tournant de la fuite de
varennes en juin 91 quand le roi la nuit
du 20 au 21
disparaît de ses appartements à paris au
château des tuileries parce que on l'a
ramené de versailles depuis octobre 89
donc déjà il est un peu dans une prison
à ciel ouvert dont son palais au coeur
de paris surveillé par les milices
jacobine sans culottes qui bon lui
interdisent d'aller par exemple en week
end dans sa résidence de saint cloud
donc louis saez se sent prisonnier ils
sont unis les révoltés contre les
mesures anti catholique de la révolution
la constitution civile du clergé qui
exige un serment aux prêtres et qu'ils
nationalisent tous les biens d'église
oui ça ce n'est pas du tout favorable à
toutes ces mesures il va même à apposer
son veto sur la constitution civile du
clergé est là et la répression qui peut
s'ensuivre et donc il fuit à varennes et
la légende veut que laura son retour de
varennes le peuple de paris impose un
silence de roy
antimonarchique lorsque louis saez
revient tout tout poussiéreux de son
voyage de plusieurs jours arrêté à à
l'est de la france et il ya quelque
chose qui est délégitimer désacraliser
et le roi devient comme l'écrit dans ton
lui-même comme il le dit dans ton aux
jacobins très rapidement avant même le
retour de louis saez danton dit le roi a
été enlevé soit parce que c'est un
traître soit parce qu'il est imbécile
imbéciles c'est son terme et un roi
imbéciles mêmes imbéciles ne peut pas
gouverner il peut pas renier et donc
pour la première fois en france ce
n'était pas le cas avant on demande une
république mais et danton comme
robespierre deviennent républicains tout
l'été avant il ne l'avait pas manifesté
et là ils le deviennent ouvertement ils
le deviennent de plus en plus
ouvertement même si après la fuite de
varennes mans c'est un épisode parce que
j'ai essayé dans mon livre de raconter
ces petits silence de l'histoire c'est à
dire les fois où l'historien doit aller
interroger les ses petits secrets ces
interstices ou où l'histoire aurait pu
être différente après la la fille de
varenne leroy revient le la majorité
parlementaire essaie d'imposer une
répression de tous ceux qui demandent
une république et
marat danton sous son le coup d'une
arrestation ainsi que camille desmoulins
et robespierre n'en mène pas large et se
cache un peu à paris chez les du blé ils
sont tous très proches à ce moment-là
marat danton des moulins robespierre ils
sont complètement dans le même camp là
on voit on voit mara là on va vraiment
le radical des rats des radicaux mais
ils sont comme lui à ce moment là l'ami
du peuple radicale dès le début lui le
plus radical alors vous avez dit tout à
l'heure qu'effectivement robespierre
était le considérer comme un fanatique
il faut il faut mesurer
aussi des titres qu'ils avaient plus
fanatiques que lui il ya toujours plus à
gauche que robespierre
les hébertisme les exagérer etc mais
quelqu'un qui était plus centriste que
robespierre c'était dans ton nom et donc
c'est intéressant de voir comment tous
discute et danton mara robespierre cédé
3 tête un peu de la montagne c'est à
dire le la branche
la gouille la gauche quasiment
extrémistes de 2 de la convention
nationale à partir de la chute du trône
et ils vont avoir une autorité certaine
victor hugo en parle largement dans son
roman 93 me vaincre il invente un
dialogue entre marat danton
et robespierre où chacun a vraiment son
langage sa radicalité sa posture parce
que c'est aussi très très imagée et tous
font la révolution même si le premier à
mourir ça sera marc a assassiné par une
jeune femme sharon corr ça va être un
tournant aussi je vous le disais comment
cette émission gérard depardieu qui
avait joué dans ton dans le film me
majda me disais pour m'expliquer comment
il voyait dans ton il me disait au fond
c'était des jeunes gens qui ne dormait
jamais et c'est pour ça qu'ils vont
finir par s'entretuer et j'ai toujours
gardé cette image parce qu'il est génial
depardieu donc en général il a le sens
de tout ça et est ce que est ce que vous
le confirmer s qu'effectivement il ne
dormait jamais celui qui dormaient le
mois on a envie de dire c'est
robespierre
il était tout le temps attelé à la tâche
ces journées quand il est membre du
comité de salut public
président du club des jacobins président
de la convention nationale c'est le cas
en septembre 1793 il est tout le temps
occupé l'espace d'un d'une tribune à une
autre d'un bureau a aussi un le soir
chez les du plein où il écrit ses
discours il entretient une
correspondance très importante aussi
avec de nombreuses marques ont voix
lasse et c'est là ce sont
ben oui ce sont ces les archives
récemment acquise je pense par la france
et il faut bien bien voir parce que
danton en plus il a une vie alors donc
il est encore plus occupé et il dort
angle peut-être encore moins mais il
faut voir qu'à ce moment là ils sont en
train de refaire le monde ils ont abattu
la révolution a abattu en un mois
pendant l'été 89 elle abat un système
millénaire lorsqu'un régime saturé milan
des traditions un ordre qui que personne
n'avait remise en cause et qu'il est
tout à coup s'effondre littéralement
comme un château de cartes et tout est à
refaire tout est possible d'une certaine
manière ils ont beaucoup de travail y
voit être géniaux parce qu'il ya eu un
déploiement d'intelligence à ce moment
là qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire quand on lit leurs textes
de ces fascinants
quand on voit les travaux de l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui c'est pas le même
niveau 1 non non c'est pas la même
construction mais inclut vocabulaire
est différent mais mais mais c'est
passionnant comme en 1789 tout s'est
quasiment joué et la radicalité
comme l'expliqué françois furet de 93 94
se retrouvent parfois déjà en 89 avec ce
cataclysme ressentie par par sommes
toute une population qui se sent
véritablement unis compte qu'on va
appeler plus tard l'ancien régime mais
ce qui conduit en priorité la révolution
de 89 c'est la haine de l'aristocratie
c'est le premier sentiment et des
privilèges et des privilèges dont
bénéficient du même par contre-coup mai
la haine de l'aristocratie et si vivace
même des gens modérés des élus modérés
sous la révolution comme barnave par
exemple assez modérée de gauche mais
modérée
qui va être envoyée à l'échafaud comme
beaucoup sous la terreur barnave il a
toujours gardé rancune à deviner de
grenoble il a toujours gardé rancune à
l'aristocratie d'occuper les premières
loges au théâtre par exemple et sa mère
avaient été chassés d'un soir d'une loge
au théâtre mais comme une malpropre et
il a il a toujours considéré qu'il
fallait se venger mais il faut voir ce
qu'a été la ségrégation aux états unis
entre les blancs et les noirs la
ségrégation existe en france par an tout
l'ancien régime les roturiers non non il
ya des tas de choses auxquelles ils
n'ont pas accès les premières places au
théâtre les places d'officier dans
l'armée un certain nombre de métiers etc
etc bien sûr alors entièrement d'accord
avec ce que vous dites il ya une société
si
classifiés encadré chacun est mis dans
des cases et même entre aristocrates il
y à une hiérarchie féroce par exemple la
baronne oberkirch qui vient de d'alsace
et qui arrive à paris à versailles dans
les années 80 elle découvre l'étiquette
à versailles si on ne prouve pas une
ancienneté antérieure à 1400 l'année
1400 on ne peut pas être de certains
balle de certains
c'est là que la langue française date du
xiiie siècle après sept ans et il m'a
d'ailleurs d'où il sortait on les a pris
à eux alors d'après ce que j'ai vu en
fait on a pris ce qu'il y avait un
château des fées des nobles ou après il
ya le l'abbé sieyès qui disait qu'elle
lui avec son son et ses caisses que le
tiers état à rien qu'est ce qu'il veut
devenir tout où il a un peu de tout
résumer c'est tout ou rien et ils ont
décidé d'être tous parce que tout était
permis tout leur était permis au nom de
la justice m'essayais sylla effet la
motion il était le seul à l'avoir
proposé alors qu'ils étaient moins
radicaux que d'autres il a proposé de
renvoyer deux renvoyés de france tous
les descendant d'aristocrates c'était
une mesure j'ai à dire quasiment
racialiste de d'exclure tous les
aristocrates et elissa formule exacte
s'était il faut renvoyer dans les forêts
de franconie tous et tous ces
aristocrates qui se prétendaient être
des descendants des croire des franc
fort et de francs connu voilà parce que
en fait il y avait cette division il
voulait pas de descendants des gaulois
qui avait été vaincu donc été divisée de
10 dt des descendants des francs qui
avaient vaincu les romains ce que l'on
pensait à ce moment là et alors c'est
fou dernière est ce qu'on va faire une
pause et on continuera juste après mais
au fond robespierre comme dans ton sont
des des figures très important qu'ils
incarnent le tiers état mais ils vont
avoir le pouvoir très peu de temps en
réalité un pour nous c'est toute la
révolution c'est c'est comme une espèce
de long duel entre entre danton et
robespierre qui finit sur l'échafaud mai
mais les périodes où ils ont le pouvoir
véritablement le pouvoir c'est très
court d'abord c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à
se souvenir de danton et robespierre de
se les représenter
uniquement frères ennemis mais au début
ils font la révolution ensemble ils sont
ils sont frères alliés complémentaires
quand ils font la révolution et c'est
passionnant de les suivre quand ils vont
gagner le pouvoir mais c'est quoi le
pouvoir à l'époque c'est pas seulement
d'un titre une dans une institution
publique
c'est l'opinion publique et dans ton va
s'imposer en l'opinion publique aux
cordeliers aux jacobins et robespierre
va être le roi des jacobins pendant
quasiment toute la révolution jusqu'à sa
mort et donc ils vont gagner l'opinion
publique ensuite ils vont exercer les
fonctions et là où c'est très rigolo
presque est paradoxal c'est que alors
que robespierre et dès le début députés
bénéficiant d'une aura exceptionnelle
des 89 dont on va réussir à s'imposer
par le coup de canon et par le 10 août
92 il va devenir appris à lâcher des
tuileries la chute du roi qu'il
organisait à l'orchestré fusil au côté
il va devenir ministre de la justice
c'est lui qui va organiser la lutte
contre l'envahisseur étranger remporté
donc la bataille de valmy en septembre
le 20 septembre 92 et c'est là sa
fameuse phrase de il faut de l'audace de
l'audace toujours de l'audace encore de
l'audace toujours de l'audace et c'est
vrai que danton et le jeu les qualifiés
ainsi le premier personnage premières
figures historiques charismatique
providentiel de la république parce que
la république vient de naître et elle a
déjà une
salve à quelque chose de salvateur avec
danton qui repousse l'ennemi comme un
clemenceau si vous voulez il dit au
parisien de ne pas quitter paris i les
adjure de se battre jusqu'à la mort
2 parce qu'il faut vivre libre ou mourir
c'est une vision très guerrière cas dans
ton de l'exercice de la politique est
d'ailleurs une fois que la convention va
être adoptée la nouvelle institution
créée il va démissionner et il va petit
à petit abandonné le pouvoir mais il va
d'abord passer à la la convention
nationale puisque c'est tout à coup la
convention nationale qui gouverne la
france donc il est encore là et puis il
est dans le comité de salut public qui
est pour ainsi dire le bras armé de la
convention
et puis ensuite ce sera robespierre au
fossé des périodes très courtes c'est ça
que je veux dire où ils ont vraiment
tous les leviers du pouvoir et pas
seulement lors a cédé période assez
courte bien en fait la lal si vous
voulez la
création du gouvernement révolutionnaire
c'est le 10
10 octobre 1793 donc il ya moins d'un an
aux deux terreurs si on applique ce
qualificatif ya moins d'un an terreur et
robespierre entre au comité en juillet
93 juste après la mort de marat quand on
quitte le comité parce qu'il va des
journées à la campagne qui lui succède
il lui succède robespierre arrive aux
fonctions dans le gouvernement après
dans le ton mais il va imposer sa marque
comme personne d'autre oui mais ça ne
dure que quelques mois puisque 1 en
moins d'un an plus tard il a été de
couper moins d'un an plus tard et il se
passe entre la mort de danton en avril
94 et celle de robespierre en juillet 94
il se passe vous comptez il se passe de
trois quatre mois à peine et c'est là où
il ya le pinacle de la terreur ou
robespierre impose sa marque personnelle
et c'est là où les exécutions du
tribunal révolutionnaire la guillotine
veuve tourné quasiment à plein régime
avec des centaines d'exécutions chaque
des milliers quasiment cessé c'est assez
assez terrifiant le quand on regarde la
courbe et cette ascension de delà de la
guillotine qui est obligé de changer
même de quartier parce que comme ça ça
pue et le sang et les odeurs étaient
terribles à la dans le quartier
bourgeois de la concorde et la place de
la révolution on l'a déplacé une
première fois la bastille puis ensuite
place de la nation et
on l'éloigné un peu parce que ça semble
ont fait une pause et on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec l'historien
laurie chavanette qui publie danton et
robespierre le choc de la révolution
chez passé composé
vous avez dit d'entendre devient
ministre de la justice
après la prise des tuileries en août
1792 il ne fera rien pour arrêter les
massacres de septembre
ça lui sera reprochée d'ailleurs
et il ne va quitter ses fonctions que
pour entrer à la convention nationale
qui désormais couverts de la france
c'est lui qui fait proclamer la
république au fond un dans ton à ce
moment là ils sont ils sont vraiment sur
la même ligne
danton et robespierre mais après les
massacres de septembre on voit bien que
pour danton faudrait s'arrêter là il ya
le procès du roi le roi va être
guillotiné une fois que la royauté est
tombé que la république est proclamée il
à cette fameuse phrase adjurons ici
toute exagération
ça c'est le début on commence à voir qui
me sont ils ne seront plus tout à fait
sur la même ligne mais danton et
robespierre en 1792 sont les deux
premiers élus de paris quand il entre à
la nouvelle assemblée la convention
nationale et donc et danton exercent des
fonctions suprêmes ministre de la
justice et il dit même parce que c'est
lui qui organise aussi la guerre avec
des fonds secrets on sait pas comment
utiliser on lui reprochera lui demandera
des comptes bref mais robespierre n'a
jamais mis les mains dans le dans
l'argent public et c'est pour essayer de
gagner une guerre et il ne reprochera
jamais non plus dans ton d'avoir été
corrompus secours n'ont jamais ça
arrivera seulement plus tard à son
procès oui mais ce sera plus une
accusation de deux personnages vicieux
qui molesté la vertu plutôt que
véritablement enfin fanfaron devises
plutôt que véritablement quelqu'un qui
avait trompé de dents dans l'argent
étranger etc mémé dans ton en fait il
faut bien comprendre avec danton et
robespierre quand on les compare
c'est que danton lui une fois la
république installer les institutions
proclamé
il est son seul but en tant qu'adjuvant
du ministre de la guerre c'est de gagner
la guerre lycée que la révolution va se
fanatisés se radicaliser sans cesse tant
qu'il ya la guerre et ils poussent à
cette radicalisation
c'est pour ça qu'il est pas opposée
fondamentalement massacres de septembre
parce que c'est une radicalisation
intérieur de la révolution contre un
ennemi ex extérieurs aux portes de paris
il faut savoir que verdun et tombe la
défense de verdun la trahison de la
place forte de longhui est donc là paris
la révolution sont menacés et danton
fait front robespierre lui al'inverse
enfin surtout avoir pour mission
assignée comme mission de lutter contre
l'ennemi intérieur est un ennemi de plus
en plus comme on l'a dit vaste important
acculèrent tentaculaire au point qu'il
s'en prend aux indifférent mais là
j'aimerais bien citer 1 2 discours de
l'un et de l'autre qui schématise un peu
une deux visions différentes de faire de
la politique
danton et telus
un moment très tôt en 91
il est élu substitut du procureur de la
commune de paris bon première fois qu'il
est et il fait un discours où il
explique qu'il ya trois parties en
france le parti des anti
révolutionnaires il faut leur faire la
guerre le parti des partisans de la
révolution il faut les faux les
conforter dans leur thèse et il ya les
indifférents ceux qui hésitent qui sont
timorés qui vont pas forcément au front
par nature et dont on veut les
convaincre de se rallier à la révolution
et donc il est prêt à leur tendre la
main à utiliser l'art politique de la
persuasion pour les amener dans le camp
de la révolution là où robespierre
al'inverse lui dis qu'il ya deux peuples
en france les méchants et les amis de la
révolution et donc il ne s'agit que de
livrer une guerre à ce peuple ennemis de
la révolution sauf que ces ennemis ce
sont les indifférents par exemple ce
sont les modérés même les ultras
révolutionnaires sont des ennemis les
citera révolutionnaire c'est à dire ceux
qui sont pas assez révolutionnaires mais
qui le sont quand même comme dans dont
des moulins sont des ennemis comment
limiter comment gouverner comment éviter
les purges dans ce schéma intellectuelle
là c'est très difficile danton membres
du comité de salut public en avril 93
parle déjà le langage de la modération
et à ce moment là robespierre qu'il aime
le soutien
mais robespierre à deux moments
défendant ton c'est très important à
l'événement clé ou qui sont risquées
pour danton mais en fait en 92 bon c'est
vrai la chronologie un peu complexe il
ya aussi des girondins
jusqu'à royal et gironde il ya eu
montagnard et les girondins bon les
girondins se sont des républicains de la
première heure démocrate que l'on a
considéré comme plus bourgeois plus
moins exigeants sur les deux république
bourgeoise fondé sur la propriété voilà
le suffrage censitaire voilà clairement
et des montagnards beaucoup plus avancé
sur sur des idées sociales de la
révolution violer la souveraineté
populaire et les girondins ils vont
commettre l'erreur de taper sur dante où
ils veulent faire tomber dans ton en
accusant de corruption notamment dans on
va se défendre comme il peut mais il est
acculé tout de même et il ne rend pas
clairement des comptes sur les fonds
publics c'est un peu c'est un peu louche
mais c'étaient des fonds secrets alors
il dit d'un ton mais comment voulez vous
j'ai pas garder quittance me intègre un
texte comme ça je n'ai pas gardé
quittance des notes de frais de des
fonds secrets vous comprenez bien et
d'arguments qui sera réutilisé
par des hommes politiques très connu
voilà c'est pratique et robespierre
défendante on met du coup dans ton à
cause des girondins est renvoyé dans le
camp de robespierre alors qu'ils
cherchaient un compromis avec les
girondins
finalement il est renvoyé ses pénates et
il va être de plus en plus radicale avec
robespierre pour faire chuter la gironde
c'est le qui voit des amis de la
révolution des frères des pères
fondateurs de la révolution qui vont
être envoyés à l'échafaud et robespierre
lui va à ce moment là dans ton parent au
moment de l'exécution des girondins il
part à la campagne après le après
l'assassinât de marat après l'assassinât
de marat
quand on voit que les girondins vont de
plus en plus être exterminés ce sont des
entre d'anciens amis à lui et il part à
la campagne dans sa champagne
avec sa femme ses enfants il va à la
pêche il veut pas voir le sang couler
dans paris et d'antan lui ai alors que
robespierre insiste pour radicaliser la
révolution qui d'un coup il ya une
passation de témoin entre danton qui
part et robespierre qui accaparent les
là le pouvoir
aux procédés député girondin robespierre
demande d'abord
c'est la wii il devient de plus en plus
le défenseur du peuple opprimé 1 et pour
lui vous le montrer dans votre livre la
révolution devient une guerre sociale
mais c'est très clairement ça c'est une
guerre sociale ou pour robespierre il ya
une terminologie il combat contre
l'aristocratie des riches c'est à dire
la révolution c'est aussi un transfert
de pouvoir de souveraineté mais aussi de
propriété est propriété de l'église ça
s'est fait rapidement dès 1790 la
nationalisation des biens de l'église
mais ensuite c'est prendre le large en
des grandes familles de la bourgeoisie
ou des aristocrates qui ont encore des
châteaux des titres et donc il faut
savoir que quand on décapite et
quand on quand on fusille est un immigré
ou un aristocrate tous ces biens étaient
saisis spoliés et devenez possession de
la république parce que c'était un
contre-révolutionnaire et donc
énormément de bien de fortune sont ainsi
rentrés dans les caisses de l'état ça
arrivera aussi dans la délibération est
la fin de l'occupation a exactement les
exactement pareil mais à ce moment là il
ya cette conviction que la carro
bestiaire que la révolution doit doit
doit basculer dans une deuxième phase de
sa radicalité du progrès d'ailleurs
c'est lui qui va rédiger en grande
partie la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1793 moins connus qui
commence article 1
chaque individu a droit au bonheur
social et c'est là la différence de
robespierre par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres c'est qu'il a compris plus tôt
la radicalité de la révolution son
horizon naturel
démocratique
et puis aussi la fusion de cette
exigence morale de fusion du public et
du privé et je sais pas que si on doit
dire qu'aujourd'hui de cette
moralisation de la vie publique
qu'elle a une raison il est il a
toujours ses partisans d'ado jour il ya
toujours des gens qui vous diront à peu
près où qu'ils penseront la même chose
que robespierre à cette époque là oui
c'est toujours aussi révolutionnaire des
bennes d'ailleurs il était contre la
peine de mort il était beau le suffrage
universel
ils étaient pour une moralisation
extrême des biens des biens de
de l'état des deniers des contre
l'aristocratie des riches
voilà tout ça aujourd'hui on l'entend
toujours on retrouve de ce cet idéal
robespierrisme et j'ai envie de dire pas
seulement dans le camp d'un jean luc
mélenchon ou d'une extrême gauche il est
récupéré par d'autres partis certains
concernant enfin nationalistes ont
récupéré ont essayé de récupérer
robespierre mais il est la figure de
d'une démocratie très exigeante où
vraiment le le le celui qui exerce les
fonctions de l'état doit rendre compte
au peuple de son argent et par exemple
c'est sous la révolution au moment du
procès contre danton qu' il y à déjà
cette mesure qui convient d'adapter
adopté il ya il ya quatre ans qui est de
vérifier les comptes la fortune des
députés pour être bien sûr qu'ils ont
exactement la même somme d'argent quand
il occupe les fonctions et quand ils
quittent ya le même contrôle déjà au
temps de la révolution voulue par
saint-just robespierre dont on lui
l'aller pas jusque-là furie alors on a
bien compris donc dans ton quitte le
pouvoir en septembre 93
robespierre lui succède au comité de
salut public
c'est là qui fait le procès des députés
girondins ce qui se connaît même pas du
tout dans ton et c'est à ce moment là tu
vas commencer la terreur ce qu'on
appelle la terreur c'est là c'est quand
robespierre et aux affaires au pouvoir
la terreur elle est exigée par les sans
culottes c'est à dire par le peuple qui
occupe le facchi entre dans la
convention nationale on rentre dans une
période là très particulière dont on se
souvient aujourd'hui avec avec effroi
mais en fait il ya eu un grand paradoxe
dans la révolution c'est que il ya une
légitimation une sacralisation du 14
juillet l'insurrection populaire qui
balaie toutes les vieilles institutions
par la force par l'armée par le canon et
en même temps assez peu violente man ya
eu quand même des têtes coupées mais
veut y a pas tant que ça dans une
bataille dans la rue
mais c'est pas ça ça va pas durer ça
dure ça dure 24 heures et basse
mais ensuite le problème c'est que
comment dire pop d'arrêter de prendre
les armes pour toujours demander de
nouvelles mesures parce que ça va se
produire à de nombreuses reprises le 10
août le peuple prend les armes contre le
roi bon à la limite certes parce qu'on
change de régime mais quand on est en
république qu'il y a des députés élus et
que le peuple sans culottes des faubourg
saint-antoine sa marceau fonce sur
l'assemblée pour exiger d'eux le vote de
mesures pic à la main en menaçant de
couper des têtes on rentre dans une
autre logique et du coup c'est là un peu
quelque chose d'assez intéressant c'est
que la terreur
s'appuie sur ce mouvement populaire mais
en même temps le gouvernement est de
plus en plus violents parce que il veut
en imposer aux sans culottes leur dire
ni n'ayez crainte nous faisons le boulot
à votre place comme dit dans ton nous
devons être terrible pour dispenser le
peuple de l'être mais on retrouve ça au
20e siècle on retrouve ça aujourd'hui
aussi il ya des mesures comprend pour
montrer au peuple qu'on est dur mais
c'est c'est le droit d'exception c'est
le droit d'exception mais c'est aussi
une
une psychologie de gestion de la foule
en armes alors il faut l'adoucir
et quand on ne peut pas la massacrer
parce que les jamais massacrés en fait
sous la révolution non parce que l ai
jamais massacrés et sauf au moment de
prairial un peu plus tard en l'an iii
après robespierre il n'y a pas de
massacre de foule le gouvernement
s'appuie sur la foule sur le pouls sur
la rue et robespierre notamment et ça
c'est assez méconnu et j'ai trouvé des
textes ou vraiment il faut transformer
le d'opinion sur son rôle dans dans en
1793 il appuie énormément en réalité le
mouvement insurrectionnel parisien
ensuite il va essayer de l'étouffer mais
c'est lui qui lui donne un peu son envol
quand il est à la fois président des
jacobins président de la convention
nationale et membre des comités bref
mais tous les pouvoirs si on peut dire
et robespierre va amener une
radicalisation de la révolution c'est
lui qui va c'est certes danton qui fait
adopter le tribunal révolutionnaire
mais c'est robespierre qui va lui donner
ce visage ultra répressif ultra
expéditif avec des mesures adoptées
progressivement mais qu'il va sans cesse
demandé corps et âme et c'est lui qui va
donner ce visage de très particulier à
la terreur qui fait que c'est une
période de un an même moi quand
robespierre exerce le pouvoir
depuis la mort de danton dans quelques
mois ou vraiment ça va être le culte de
l'être suprême la suppression de
l'avocat de témoin lors d'un procès ça
va être l'époque des grandes purges
des grands la dernière fois où ils font
front commun danton et robespierre c'est
contre les vers et les hébertistes
hébert alors lui les plus
révolutionnaires qui révolutionnaire il
travaille à la description des
christianisation du pays donc que ces
anti catholique à mort et ça choque à la
fois robespierre et danton qui font
front commun et qu'ils vont réussir à
battre les hébertistes donc à les faire
arrêter juger et ils seront mieux tinée
quelques mois plus tard juste avant
l'heure mais ses derniers moments où ils
sont d'accord l'union faisant la force
en fait rien ne peut arrêter danton et
robespierre quand ils se comptent ils
constituent un temps des mondiaux parce
qu'ils ont deux visages différents de
légitimité deux histoires différentes
dans la révolution et ils sont ils sont
vraiment indestructible quand ils font
front commun et là on est en décembre 93
quand dans ton revient de la pêche en
gros pour lutter contre les
déchristianisation seul et ce qu'on
appelait les hébertistes
les partisans du père duchesne et qu'on
appelait aussi les exagérer alors il y
avait les exagérer les enragés bon le
prêtre rouge enfin il y en a un paquet d
des ultras radicaux des ultras
révolutionnaire et danton robespierre
vont les vont combattre leurs idées
et robespierre va à vau va citer
notamment dans un discours c'est assez
beau is it voltaire qui disait si dieu
n'existait pas il faudrait l'inventer
à tous ceux qui crient dénoncent ce
qu'ils sont pour l'athéisme qui font des
fêtes de la raison dans le notre dame de
paris avec des femmes des salaires qui
court dans tout paris sur des chars ont
cédé beuvry énorme à coups de wie coup
de prostitution enfin ses traits
c'est un ramassis de devises que ne
supporte pas robespierre parce que
l'athéisme c'est aussi le vice alors que
la religion vient régler les moeurs
depuis toujours et robespierre lui
toujours cette vision donc d'un être
suprême il croit en l'immortalité de
l'âme mais il croit dans le énormément
dans la correction des vis des individus
et si on peut pas les corriger il faut
les supprimer
et donc il va amener la révolution à ce
tournant quasi religieux n'ont pas quasi
religieux religieux en juin 1794 alors
après avoir éliminé les hébertistes
pourquoi est-ce que robespierre se
retourne contre danton
et bien après avoir éliminé les
hébertistes après avoir tapé un coup à
gauche il va taper comme on dit un peu
un coup à droite un peu comme staline
quelques quelques années quelques même
décennie plus tard au fond mais la
comparer avec un paradis où gauche puis
les cabanes de droite et au fond à la
fin il ya plus que mort à quoi oui c'est
à peu près ça dans la logique de l'homme
d'une personnalisation du pouvoir même
si staline beaucoup plus personnalisé le
pouvoir que robespierre et la garder
davantage il a gardé beaucoup plus
longtemps
même s'il avait aussi la petite vérole
com com com danton et robespierre
mais effectivement robespierre
devient la cible avec les comités de
toute une politique qu'on appelle de la
clémence une politique d'indulgence
demandé par camille desmoulins danton un
autre qui s'appelle philippot et filippo
par exemple c'est un ami de d'antan et
des moulins filippo il revient de vendée
de l'ouest il a vu les massacres des as
vu de ses propres yeux les noyades dans
dans la loire il revient il dénonce tous
ces faits ces crimes commis par des
députés en fonction en mission à l'ouest
et le comité lui dit de d'écraser la
sphère d'étouffer la faire et finalement
il publie un livre des moulins reprend
lui aussi la charge contre les comités
contre les excès de du gouvernement
révolutionnaire et robespierre va être
un peu mis en demeure de choisir
entre
appartenir au camp des indulgent ou bien
les réprimer et comme st juste le pouce
quand même du côté de la radicalité
parce que st juste un rôle majeur dans
la lutte contre les d'anthony sts et
robespierre vin peut épouser les vues de
saint-just de billaud varenne de tout le
camp gouvernemental
pour faire chuter dans ton mais une fois
que robespierre a décidé la chute de
danton de camille desmoulins et de
cesser modéré camille desmoulins qui est
son ami de toujours son ami de toujours
son ami d'enfance du autant du collège
avait mis le grand est dont on a envoyé
même la femme à la guillotine alors elle
il était le témoin de mariage de camille
desmoulins c'est un peu ce qui m'a donné
aussi envie de de percer ce mystère de
robespierre de des moulins de danton
c'est un roman si tu c'est un mystère il
ya une intrigue qui est un peu le fil
conducteur de tout ce ce choc de la
révolution cette biographie croisée
comment on en vient à envoyer son
meilleur ami à l'échafaud c'est quelque
chose qui ne relève toujours du
mystérieux
et robespierre quand il décide la chute
donc de camille desmoulins il le fait
pas à moitié mieux il va véritablement
être l'auteur de leur chute en
rédigeant des notes contre les d'anthony
stokes comme ça qu'on les appelle yala
robespierristes lennon tunis mais là
c'est les d'anthony sts rédigeant a donc
un pré-rapport d'accusation contre les
d'anthony sts il va à la tribune
empêcher que danton puisse s'exprimer à
la tribune de l'assemblée pour se
défendre il va interdire cela il va
faire mettre les accusés hors des débats
pendant le procès dont on va être mis
hors des débats il n'aura plus droit à
s'exprimer plus droit de se défendre et
au bout de trois jours il va être
envoyée à l'échafaud
et il va surtout robespierre convoqué et
ça s'est jamais vraiment préciser dans
l'historiographie on le sait on s'est
assez mal il va convoquer le vice
président du tribunal le premier jour du
tribunal de du procès
il va le convoquer pour le devine lui
donner ses directives pour s'assurer du
verdict est donc dans ton est guillotiné
implique des moulins et tous leurs amis
quelques mois plus tard en juillet on
est en avril en juillet c'est
robespierre qui renversait saint-just
ils sont tous amenés aussi l échafaud
qu'est ce qui a fait se retourner cette
convention qui suivait robespierre
jusqu'à présent jusqu'à laisser mourir
dans ton et qui tout à coup le venge
c'est vous avez dit une des choses les
plus justes c'est à dire que la
convention a toujours voté on n'aura
jamais mis souvent un cadeau sous le
sous la gorge et le marais a toujours
cru que robespierre pouvait être un
recours le marais c'est à dire s'il est
un peu timorée c'est à dire la majorité
ce qui j'image d'un camp à un autre qui
hésite et qui se cachent souvent les
majorités qui font les majorités voilà
et toujours ils ont vu en robespierre en
recours parce que il était quand même
assez tolérants vis-à-vis des des
prêtres et donc c'était toujours moins
dangereux que les fanatiques
déchristianisation et robespierre nos
coûts va perdre la majorité parce que il
va
prononcer à un moment un discours tout
se joue en deux jours à la chute de
robespierre
il va prononcer un discours le 8
thermidor c'est à dire on est le 26
juillet 1794 il prononce un discours il
n'a pas parlé il n'est pas intervenue
depuis quasiment un mois ni au comité ni
à l'assemblée il a écrit un long
discours et le prononce et dans ce
discours il demande une nouvelle purge
une nouvelle élimination et tout le
monde se disent c'est moi le prochain
c'est moi qui passe et tout le monde
dans le camp de dès des amis de danton
notamment ce qu'il en reste il avait
beaucoup de partisans vont réussir à
rallier les timorés de l'assemblée et
d'un coup il va y avoir la conspiration
de la peur tous ceux qui ont peur d'être
envoyée à l'échafaud qui vont se
retourner en 24 heures contre
robespierre et celui qui va organiser
cette conspiration de la peur contre
robespierre c'est notamment foucher qui
promis à un bel avenir sous napoléon
ministre de la police et fouché va
organiser des rangs mineurs ayant été un
sacré
as écrit guy yotine abbas et lui il
était passé dans le camp un autre trait
déchristianisation à lyon vous ai tiré à
coups de mitraille sur les lyonnais tu
es sans pitié un
robespierre le connaissait depuis longue
date foucher on aurait voulu se marier
avec la soeur de robespierre il ya eu
toute une histoire d'amour où déjà il
était pas copain depuis le début et
fouché se sentant qu'il est proche de la
guillotine va avoir la tête de
robespierre mais vous connaissez
peut-être
ce mot de robespierre quand il est
accusé le 9 thermidor il dit c'est dans
ton que vous voulez venger c'est donc ça
c'est le vous voulez venger danton et
les députés lui répondent tu ne peux pas
parler robespierre ce qu on espère avec
des séries avaient la gorge serrée il
avait du mal à s'exprimer qu'en cas de
crise il faut une présence physique il
l'a pas et on lui répond c'est le sens
de danton qui t'étouffe voilà rebelles
robespierre comprend qu'il envoyait à
l'échafaud c'est la vengeance de
d'antoni sts les qui a gagné le duel est
ce que c'est robespierre qui envoyait
dans ton le premier oui à l'échafaud
mais c'est le un peu le spectre de
danton qui va envoyer robespierre par la
suite à l'échafaud celui qui a gagné aux
yeux de l'histoire en tout cas en france
c'est dans ton il ya des rues danton
partout il ya des statuts dans ton on
aime dans ton on n'aime pas robespierre
il ya une station de métro robespierre à
montreuil parce que tu danses des
municipalités communistes mais rien
d'autre à paris ou très peu de choses
même au niveau français
l'histoire a choisi en tout cas les
français la france a choisi dans ton est
ce que après la chute de robespierre
est-ce qu'on cesse de guillotiné en
france
eh bien c'est ce qu'on avait pensé oui
mais en fait le il ya le début de la
légende noire de robespierre néant
thermidor déjà du vivant de robespierre
il est très critiqué par beaucoup il
incarne sur scène ne veut rien qu'un de
la terreur et et les tyrannies et la
tyrannie voire de le despotisme
judiciaire et puis une personnalisation
du régime il est déjà critiquée mais en
thermidor il va se passer quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable c'est que il va
y avoir le jugement des terroristes ce
qu'on appelle les terroristes qui ont
exercé le pouvoir de la manière la plus
marquée pendant sept années de
gouvernement révolutionnaire et lors de
ce procès des milliers de
témoins vont défiler à la barre pour
juger les anciens membres du tribunal
révolutionnaire pour l'ong fouquier
tinville pour juger les crimes de
carrier tous les massacres commis à
nantes pour juger ainsi les ce qu'on
appelle les complices la queue de
robespierre et d'un coup il va y avoir
des révélations sur sur toutes les
affaires robespierre et sur cette époque
et on va prendre conscience de l'horreur
de véritablement que la terreur portait
bien son nom elle terrorise et des gens
c'est pas c'est pas fictif et on passe
tous les guillotinés et ils vont
quasiment tous guillotine est la plus
grande purge de la révolution c'est au
moment du 9 thermidor il ya une centaine
de ces contres robespierre contre
robespierre envoyé exactement la plus
grande pulsé contre les robespierristes
ensuite certains vont être envoyé au
bagne à sinnamary on va les condamner à
la déportation
certains vont être guillotiné
et puis la légende noire de robespierre
va naître à ce moment là tant et si bien
beaucoup de gens vont publier dès leur
mémoire sur ce qu'ils ont vécu en prison
comment était robespierre dans la vie
privée va y avoir des portraits de lui
on va se moquer de lui de son apparence
physique il va y avoir le début de la
légende noire tant et si bien que sa
soeur qui est toujours vivante charlotte
va prendre la défense de son frère
pendant
qu'il était un enfant adorable qu'il
était un enfant adorable mais peut-être
jour défaire une parce qu'on est allé
vite dans l'histoire et on va parler de
thermidor mais très vite parce qu'on a
fini très vite face mandat finit berba
alors du coup on va dire en notre faim
et notre commencement en fait tout se
joue comme raconte charlotte robespierre
et c'est pareil avec danton tout se joue
à l'enfance et en fait quand on veut
percer la psychologie de ses personnages
comme j'ai essayé de le faire il ya plus
de 100 pages du livre consacré à
l'enfance la famille d'où ils viennent
et comment ils ont eu des blessures
narcissiques qui les a aussi amené à
avoir une représentation du monde très
différente et originale
novatrices il ya une phrase de
robespierre ce serait joli de finir
là-dessus il dit à une femme en 1787
qu'il drague clairement il lui dit ni on
pas le bonheur pour moi même je me
console en essayant de l'amener aux
autres et donc c'est absolument
fondamental de se plonger dans l'enfance
pour savoir comment ils ont évolué d'où
ils viennent et puis ensuite il ya bien
sûr que vous l'avez dit la leur leurs
destins posthume c'est à dire comment la
mémoire dans la littérature on a on a
réveillé le duel et court jusqu'à nous
encore aujourd'hui danton et robespierre
le choc de la révolution c'est le titre
de ce livre le réchauffer n'être que
vous avez publié aux éditions passées
composé merci d'avoir passé cette
émission avec nous merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]